[Música]
donald trump sostiene que ganó al menos
que le roben la elección el presidente
cargó contra lo que llamó una corrupta
maquinaria demócrata en michigan y
pensilvania y prometió una gran ofensiva
legal por su parte joe biden llama a la
calma en medio de las protestas y
señalamientos de fraude electoral
y es que dos días después de la elección
aún no hay resultados definitivos el
candidato demócrata joe biden está seis
votos electorales del número anhelado
con 264 frente a los 214 de donald trump
según la agencia de noticias ap que ya
le otorga arizona by the end
la pandemia no da tregua en europa el
continente registro máximo de contagios
y suma más de 12 millones de casos
francia reportó un nuevo récord de más
de 58 mil positivos en 24 horas
italia también registró máximos de
contagios y muertes mientras que en
reino unido el primer ministro boris
johnson volvió a defender las nuevas
medidas de confinamiento
[Música]
hola cómo están buenas noches en américa
latina y de todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24 mi nombre es
talan austria y hoy que 5 de noviembre
sean bienvenidos
eeuu continuó en vilo dos días después
de la elección presidencial mientras
sigue el conteo en varios estados
el presidente de donald trump cuestionó
la integridad del sistema electoral del
país al poner en entredicho sin pruebas
la legalidad de millones de votos y
abrió la puerta a un largo litigio sobre
el resultado de las elecciones
escuchemos sus palabras si cuentan los
votos legales ganó con facilidad si
cuentan los votos ilegales ellos pueden
intentar robar la elección de nosotros
si cuentan los votos que llegaron tarde
estamos observando los con mucha
fortaleza pero muchos llegaron tarde y
yo ya gané decisivamente muchos estados
críticos incluyendo victorias masivas en
florida iowa indiana ohio
para mencionar sólo algunos gramos en
estos y muchas otras victorias
a pesar de la interferencia electoral
por parte de tecnología los medios como
todos lo saben ganamos por cifras
históricas esperemos que esto sea
aclarado espero que sea pronto muy
pronto posiblemente pasará por un
proceso un proceso legal y como ustedes
saben yo he reclamado ciertos estados el
estado reclamando estados ambos podemos
hacerlos pero yo tengo una sensación de
que los jueces van a tener que hacer un
fallo en un fallo pero ha habido muchos
juegos que no podemos salir en ese país
muchas gracias enlazamos con rafael
peñalver abogado constitucionalista
muchas gracias por esta comunicación
abogado es inminente un largo litigio en
la corte suprema de eeuu sobre el
resultado de las elecciones puede trump
conseguir en este lugar la reelección
muy buenas noches y estamos viviendo
momentos históricos sin precedentes en
los eeuu el presidente de trump está
alegando fraude que están alegando que
se le está robando su elección diciendo
que los votos emitidos que fuera de los
en personas fueron a votar el día de la
elección que todo lo demás no no vale
esto es totalmente en contra de las
leyes de los 50 estados norteamericanos
que permiten el voto por correo el voto
por lo que se llama enap sentí malote y
que siempre se ha aceptado como legítimo
como válido y que está regido por las
más estrictas es las más estrictas
condiciones el presidente está alegando
que esto no cuenta y esto lo va a llevar
a la corte ya ha presentado algunos
algunas demandas judiciales en las
cortes de pensilvania de georgia y de
wisconsin y vamos a ver hacia dónde se
dirige el país hoy en día los dos
partidos políticos se pueden decir que
son los dos bufetes de abogados
grande del país cómo varían las
legislaciones entre estos estados en
disputa abogado y que puede lograr trump
con estas acciones judiciales que ha
interpuesto
y hemos quedado que estás destruyendo en
mi opinión destruyendo la a la
barrabrava sé que es el estado de
derecho que es lo que une a este país el
estado de el respeto al proceso
electoral
muy lamentable lo que puede lograr es
que las cortes intervengan es lo que
quiere es básicamente que la corte diga
que todo voto que vino por correo no
cuenta que todo voto que no fue en
presencia de la persona que fue el día
de la elección a votar no cuenta y eso
no es lo que la ley dice en eeuu no hay
un colegio electoral nacional aquí son
50 estados cada uno tiene sus leyes sus
normas electorales y la corte suprema
del país es muy difícil que se meta que
se involucre en temas locales de tener
elecciones locales estatales lo hizo en
el año 2000 en el caso de muchos
contralor y el presidente quiere que
vuelva a hacer eso la corte ahora que
especialmente qué
de nombrar a un nuevo miembro de la
corte suprema la ayuda de la juez amy
vaart y el presidente estima que él
puede lograr que la corte suprema
intervenga esto es un proceso largo
proceso difícil con esta jueza e miconi
barrick no se identifica abogado que
entonces está destruyendo el sistema
legal estadounidense que tanto lo
estaría destruyendo en sus palabras
habrá una crisis institucional en eeuu
tras estas elecciones mira
el temor mío que aquí se está
básicamente se está se está dando es que
candela se le está tirando un fósforo a
la gasolina
a ver si hay reacción del pueblo las
personas que lo apoyan a él que salgan a
la calle y esto es algo que yo jamás
pensé que pudiera pasar en eeuu pero
aquí estamos en vísperas de un proceso
que puede terminar mal
rafael peñalver muchas gracias por esta
comunicación por su análisis él es
abogado constitucionalista y es que
previamente el candidato demócrata joe
biden desde wilmington delaware también
realizó una declaración en la que hizo
un llamado a la calma a la paciencia y
se mostró optimista por la tendencia que
tiene en el conteo de los votos
escuchemos
cada voto debe ser contado y eso es lo
que vamos a buscar en estos momentos y
eso es lo que debe ser en la democracia
a veces es un poco desorganizada a veces
requiere algo de paciencia también pero
esa paciencia ha sido recompensada ahora
por más de 240 años parece más del
gobierno al sistema del gobierno y eso
ha sido el vídeo del mundo en kenia y
seguimos sintiéndonos la senadora y yo
nos sentimos muy bien y c's por cómo
están las cosas en estos momentos no
tenemos duda de que cuando se termine la
cuenta la señora gervis y yo seremos
declarados ganadores entonces le pido a
todos que mantengan la calma a todos que
mantenga la calma el proceso está
funcionando en uno de los estados que
quedan por entregar resultados
pensilvania es el que más votos
electorales otorga con 20 nuestra
enviada especial mamen sala nos detalló
cómo está el conteo y cuando se espera
el resultado definitivo
estaba previsto que se conociera este
resultado el viernes pero la secretaria
de estado hoy mismo ha anunciado que
podría ser perfectamente que esta misma
noche supiéramos quién se queda con esos
20 votos electorales que vale
pensilvania os hacía también hincapié en
una escena que estamos viviendo aquí muy
interesante que es esos seguidores de
donald trump de barrera para adentro que
piden que se detenga el conteo y de
vayas para afuera esos seguidores de joe
biden que exigen que se cuente hasta el
último voto amén que tanto has podido
recorrer este estado cuéntanos sobre su
composición cómo es su gente
y pensilvania es un estado en el que
casi más de un 44% de la población es
afroamericana y un 40% es blanca la
representación latina aquí es muy escasa
casi de un 7 por ciento pero aquí sin
duda el voto más importante es el voto
de los la clase obrera tradicionales es
el voto que han tratado de conseguir
ambos candidatos porque es el que más
peso tiene en este estado pensilvania
tiene un poquito el mismo fenómeno que
estamos viendo en otros puntos del país
las grandes ciudades están apostando por
los demócratas y las zonas de los
suburbios son las que apuestan por
jobvite por verdon por donald trump que
también estaría contando en estas zonas
con el apoyo de las mujeres blancas un
apoyo que al parecer no iba a estar tan
a su favor en estas elecciones y le está
saliendo un mejor de lo que esperaba con
el candidato demócrata y el republicano
cabeza a cabeza en la carrera
presidencial aún no se ha declarado un
ganador en seis estados
veamos cómo está el mapa electoral de la
agencia de noticias estadounidense ap
hasta el momento yo bailé en acumula 264
votos
torales y está a 6 de los 270 necesarios
para ganar mientras que donald trump
acumula a 214
este escenario político se da mientras
eeuu bate récord de contagios por kobe
19 en este segundo día consecutivo
revisemos precisamente la pandemia por
el mundo
europa registra ya 12 millones de casos
francia registró en las últimas 24 horas
58 mil 46 nuevos casos confirmados la
cifra más alta desde que se realizan
pruebas de diagnóstico a gran escala y
ha superado ya los 16 millones italia
registró 34 mil 505 nuevos contagios en
las últimas 24 horas el mayor dato jamás
registrado aunque también ahora se hacen
mucho más pruebas que los pasados meses
los muertos fueron 445 es la peor cifra
en seis meses en italia se han
contagiado más de 800 24 mil personas
desde febrero y sigue creciendo la
presión en los hospitales
grecia registró un nuevo récord de casos
y de fallecidos con dos mil 917
contagios y 29 muertes en una jornada en
la que el gobierno anunció el
confinamiento de todo el país a partir
del sábado para hacer frente al aumento
exponencial de infecciones su cifra
total de casos asciende a 49 mil 807 y
defunciones 702 y reino unido- se ha
unido a otras naciones vecinas con
nuevas medidas para hacer frente a una
alta mortalidad por el virus
desesperados por una pinta este panorama
en el centro londinense parece en el
2019 pero es la última imagen masiva en
un pub antes de un nuevo confinamiento
es como cuando te subes al metro y te
dice cuidado con las puertas que se
cierran y tienes que entrar parece la
víspera de año nuevo hay esa atmósfera
de noche viene el aire horas antes del
cierre los distritos comerciales de la
ciudad también estaban abarrotados de
personas que buscaban cierta terapia en
las compras siguiendo a gales e irlanda
del norte reino unido desde los últimos
de una serie de naciones europeas en
confinar por segunda vez tras la
reclusión de marzo
por ello los pubs y restaurantes así
como las tiendas no esenciales cerrarán
durante un mes mientras que a los
ciudadanos se les ha pedido teletrabajar
aún cuando los centros educativos
seguirán abiertos no me importa mucho
porque hemos hecho muchas compras y con
suerte será solo por cuatro semanas
obviamente es molesto
queremos hacer planes pero así es como
funciona reino unido tiene el número más
alto de muertes por kobe 19 en europa
tras las casi 500 del miércoles el país
supera ya los 48 mil fallecimientos pese
a estas cifras el gobierno británico
insiste que el confinamiento expirará el
2 de diciembre entonces espero seremos
capaces de hacer que este país vuelva a
funcionar de que negocios y tiendas
vuelvan a abrir para el periodo de
navidad pero eso depende de que todos
aportemos ahora
se espera que el banco de inglaterra
inyecta 100.000 millones de libras extra
a las empresas para ayudarlas a
enfrentar este encierro
la región de américa central hace frente
a la devastación dejada por el paso del
huracán está ya degradado a depresión
tropical hasta el momento 50 personas
han perdido la vida en la región y se
cuentan por miles los evacuados y
afectados por las intensas lluvias y
vientos en guatemala fue decretado el
estado de calamidad en 8 de los 22
departamentos en honduras los cuatro
aeropuertos internacionales fueron
afectados mientras que en el salvador y
costa rica hubo deslizamientos en el
archipiélago colombiano de san andrés
también fue decretado el estado de
calamidad pública por los daños dejados
por ella
dejamos la región y nos vamos a áfrica y
es que el ejército de etiopía declaró
hoy que ha entrado en guerra con el
gobierno de la región de tigray al norte
del país que a su vez informó que la
aviación federal ha bombardeado la
capital make l
estas palabras nuestro país ha entrado
en una guerra que no había previsto
fueron dichas por el número dos del
estado mayor del ejército etíope
teniente general verano hula el gobierno
de tigray señaló por su parte que un
avión militar ha bombardeado un complejo
militar de mikel sin saber aún los daños
que ha ocasionado o si ha habido
víctimas el primer ministro etíope
ordenó una ofensiva militar contra el
gobierno de esta región que lleva meses
midiendo un pulso de poder con el
ejecutivo federal
nuestro país ha entrado en una guerra
que no quería esta guerra es una guerra
vergonzosa no tiene sentido el pueblo de
tigray y su juventud y sus fuerzas de
seguridad no deben morir por esta guerra
sin sentido etiopía en su país llegamos
al final de esta emisión les agradecemos
mucho su compañía los invitamos a que
sigan con nosotros con actualizaciones
constantes no sólo en nuestra señal
televisiva sino información al momento
en nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
que disfrute de su noche y por favor
siga se cuidando cuídense mucho del
coronavirus
[Música]
en un instante deportes